voici la botte secrète des asperges
d'avoine là vous avez un réseau d'eau
chaude bon qui est souterrain en fait et
qui permet de récupérer les eaux tièdes
de la centrale qui se trouve juste à
côté
et ces eaux tiède circulent comme dans
un plancher chauffant sous nos asperges
avantages la précocité pour cette
primeur qui profite également de la
douceur inhabituelle des derniers jours
autre intérêt la dimension qualitative
sans variation de température l'asperge
se révèle peu filandreuse et plus
goûteuse
reste à l'accueillir un savoir faire
ancestral inchangé qui demande à minima
un mois d'apprentissage
une aiguille on creuse comme ça
on descend la gouge bien droite on fait
l'angle à 45 degrés on la sent là et un
coup elle est coupée et on la tire
les asperges récoltés sont ensuite lavés
triés conditionné sur place une
quarantaine de saisonniers il travaille
durant 4 mois cette variété blanche est
particulièrement prisée ici comme
ailleurs elle partent sur des grandes
tables je dirais
restauration épicerie fine haut de gamme
on peut en trouver également sur Tours
dans la région et nous vendons aussi
beaucoup en Asie en fait ou vous avez un
certain nombre de pays très friands de
l'asperge blanche française pour les
gourmands locaux il faudra être patient
et attendre la mi-mars pour la vente
directe le weekend